I'm Matt Welch with Nicholas P we're
here on ask a libertarian 2012 in honor
of the paperback publication of the
Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America this comes through
email Matt Connery if that's really your
name makes a clowns to the left of me
Joker's to the right reference which
will pass over at 48 years old I'm
probably not old enough to think I'll
have any social security waiting for me
but I may not be an old old enough to
start saving for my own retirement
what's the libertarian answer for us
tweeners well you know the good point
out forty eight myself and the you know
the first answer is you're gonna live to
be a hundred and you're gonna be working
until you're about ninety nine so don't
worry about retirement oh really much
we've got an upcoming story about this
if you are retiring now in the average
wage category or high-income category if
you retired in 2010 you're already
getting negative returns on your Social
Security according to any serious study
of what the payouts are gonna be so
you're already screwed this is a real
question it's a very very serious and
fundamental one we need to shift out of
Social Security as quickly as possible
by out or just stop taking money from
people who are invested in the system
already and we're gonna have to work
towards that it's going to involve
working more it's going to involve an
economic growth and it's going to
involve a little bit of pain the
question is if it's gonna be a lot of
pain on everybody or if we're gonna
minimize this by getting out of Social
Security as quickly as possible
personal finance tip start saving for
your retirement period no matter how
much money you make do what you can
you're gonna need it because right now
we don't have politicians who are
dealing with this issue forthrightly and
it is the issue it's the fiscal cliff
hanging over our heads and I know that
metaphor doesn't make any sense but it's
coming down the pike and if politicians
aren't planning for it then we have to
because it's going to be imposed upon us
in a kind of an emergency Retreat type
of setting that's it for this segment of
ask a libertarian we'll be back in just
a few short moments keep the questions
coming